hey what's up guys my name is a China
and welcome to another episode of game
programming serve today we're going to
continue off from where we left off last
week if you guys missed that episode
then go back and watch it you can need
to we're gonna basically be talking
about how the server is actually going
to deal with clients and how clients can
connect to the server so that's
obviously kind of a big deal that we
need to deal with and like that there
are there are many different ways of
actually having a server handled as
clients we're gonna talk about one of
them and we're gonna implement some kind
of system in which that will work okay
so first of all if we go into our game
class we'll see the kind of the main
area of connection so we have our to do
here that says we should connect to the
server and we are kind of connecting to
the server but remember if we look at
what we're actually doing in the client
of Connect section here what we're what
we're actually doing is we're
translating the address that we've
specified into an actual high net
address object we're creating a socket
and then we're into in our sender
connection packet we're just sending
this connection packet right we're not
actually caring about whether or not it
gets received or anything like that all
we're doing literally is we're sending a
packet that says I am connecting right I
mean like well we're literally sending
these bytes to the server and the server
will I mean I deal like literally just
like receive it I think and print it
right so processes the database dump
packet so we'll just print that it
received a packet with our contents and
that's it right there's no kind of
interconnection going on it's just
printing what it gets which in this case
is the woods you know connection packet
and that's it and then we're assuming
that the connection successful we're
sending a database so what we're
actually gonna do is we have connect
which of course returns a boolean so
we're going to basically first of all
handle the case of we didn't connect
right and the way that this is really
going to work and we're actually not
gonna do it this way and we'll see why
in a minute
but
this is like the rough idea of what
we'll start where we'll kind of start
off from so what we'll do on the same
connection back at us we have to decide
some kind of packet that we want to send
that's basically going to actually you
know send a connection packet like what
is what is a connection packet right
eventually you might find that it might
be a good idea to send the user name and
password as the connection packet right
and again if you like you know if you're
serious about security you might want to
hash the password first if you have a
database on the server which contains
all the server has access to a database
which contains every every user in it
then of course you would be storing
passwords in the database hashed not
plaintext I hope and so of course that
way you could of course just use the
client to take in the users password
hash the password there and then locally
and then send a packet which has
username and a half-two password to the
server then the server can query the
database and make sure that that user
exists and the password is indeed
correct ok that would be an ideal fairly
secure way of actually logging in a user
and in the server can of course replied
being like no the password is incorrect
or no that user doesn't exist or
whatever kind of status you want to
reply with or maybe you know
everything's successful the user is now
locked in and then that way we have
basically established a connection now
we don't have any of that yet in the
future again it might be something that
we do adding users and usernames and
passwords and stuff like that but right
now we don't we don't have the UI for it
and of course I don't really want to
spend time setting up your life for that
now or anything like that so we're gonna
skip that step entirely instead what
we're gonna do is just send our intent
to connect over to the server and that's
gonna be it right so we're literally
gonna be like I'm connecting we might
send the persons I don't even know if
we're taking in a name see that's
another problem right we're not taking
in any kind of user name or player name
everything come nameless right now and
we're gonna kind of keep it that way for
now just to keep things real simple
because I want to lay down this
framework as like I want to make it as
simple as possible and then we'll start
extending each kind of feature so it's
almost like if we had like a little tree
that we were growing right we want to
first kind of set up
it was like a binary tree or something
so it was limited in you know how many
how many nodes each or how many children
each node can have you know we're kind
of setting up the the root kind of first
and then from then we'll start expanding
each node and start kind of you know so
I mean if you really want a computer
science explanation for what I'm trying
to say you would say that I'm kind of
trying to do this development
breadth-first rather than depth-first so
instead of fully completing one feature
then moving on to the next one I'm kind
of touching on each feature and we're
going to kind of revisit them constantly
that way I think it'll keep things a bit
more interesting and also I mean I like
to have my entire game working badly
first rather than having a little little
section of my game working perfectly
again I'm sure everyone's like that as
well who wants to work on the same
feature when the rest of the game isn't
ready so you have to kind of keep
working on that so that's what we'll do
so connection packet that's probably not
gonna fly we're going to basically just
make a private private final bytes thing
here that I don't even know like I
honestly again someone's gonna have to
in fact if someone could look this up
and do the research for me and just put
it in the comments the final static like
I'm assuming we need both of them but
again if something's final then it's
obviously going to be static in the
sense that it's clearly going to be the
same for each class I can you know if
you mark something as as like Const or
static essentially in c and c++ what
you'll do is like the memory which it
gets allocated for will kind of be part
of the executable itself so if I make a
constant kind of byte or a constant char
array or something in C++ then that
string that I put in there or the data I
put in there is actually going to be
physically in the executable again this
is Java I've no idea how it works
unfortunately so if someone knows you
know if final static is needed or just
final like I'm basically just saying
this is a hard constant that is going to
be the same like I mean I would have
thought the final will kind of
implicitly make it static in a way
because you can't change it so why would
it be obviously it's gonna be the same
across all instances or does this does
making a final mean that every client
has its own memory to hold this I don't
know I've never actually thought about
it that hard and we probably don't need
to but this is just something that I
came up with on the spot right now and I
was
I wonder if that makes any sense because
I think in c-sharp you can't mark
thoughts mark something is final and
static or something all that constant
static I'm not sure anyway this is going
to be our so we'll have a bunch of these
so a subtle score just means I am I
going to switch to my convention
probably not let's just make it so
packet type connects or something and
we'll just I mean this is a byte array
will probably just we could send one
byte we could send here's what we'll do
well send one by it for this and this is
just going to be 0 1 ok we'll have
another one though that is actually a
header which it's just like gonna be 2
by it's probably that just kind of says
you know hey this is this is this is a
packet from me and for that of course we
might just pick something like 80 40 I
don't know again I'm just two random
numbers do that two random numbers and
that's more than a by of course so maybe
we'll do it like no let's do something
that we can actually will read now let's
just do like 40 and in X in hexadecimal
and like maybe maybe like 40 24 20 let's
not do that let's do it 40 40 okay it
doesn't actually matter what this is
this is just something that we can use
to verify that we're not being fed
malicious Packers obviously again it's
not particularly secure because anyone
could take compiler code or binary even
if it was super slots or whatever and be
like oh look they're sending these two
bytes at the front of every packet but
it's just something that we're doing
just to kind of have a more uniformly
formed packet if that makes any sense
and also that way we know that this is
like the beginning of a new packet and
not like you know in case a daughter
gets corrupted anyway again we might
change that I don't really care what it
said - it doesn't matter
alright so same connection packet so
we're going to basically send we're
going to construct out the our data it's
not going to be connection packet it's
going to first of all be I guess our
packet header I don't actually know how
we're going to write our byte arrays I
don't know if
we have a class that can deal with that
immediately anyway so the list probably
could in a sense I don't know if Java
has this so I'm just gonna make my own
because it's probably useful for you
guys anyway under util I'm just gonna
make a class called binary writer
there's gonna be very similar to C
sharps binary writer class if you guys
have ever used that basically well this
is going to be is an underlying list of
bytes which is going to be our buffer
it's going to have a potentially a
constructor which takes in a size a
constructor that again I would make this
a default parameter but you can't with
Java so I have to make sure constructors
here so this does nothing this will
basically instantiate the list to be in
fact we might in that case do this
instead you can put that list so I'm
going quite fast here cuz I didn't plan
on actually doing this and time is
running out but we'll have this byte and
I think we can reserve a size right yes
so initial capacity will be size okay so
we have a list of bytes here we're going
to have a probably can't do that cuz
this is frickin Java
oh okay doesn't matter we'll have I will
have to set this I probably will have
will have rice okay what right we'll do
is basically just do you know buffer dot
add data this is basically very similar
to how our ization handles this is it
this way it's just kind of we don't need
to supply the byte buffer with a preset
size this is like a dynamically kind of
dynamically growing thing here so for
this we'll do we'll just make a for loop
we'll keep it simple I mean I'm sure we
could use system to array copy or
something crazy but I am not feeling too
confident with Java API right now and
also this is probably gonna make sense
for more of you
will you know I mean we could spend all
day on this really but it's gonna do the
same thing every frickin time I don't
know if well actually not every time
because we have to convert that to N
what was that magical thing I used last
time to convert an into like a byte
array or a yeah something like that
mm I don't have to google it real quick
I I think that was something really
simple I know there's bit converter in
c-sharp but of course there's this
ridiculous thing yeah okay we'll just do
that I guess Oh
Java sometimes I hate you okay so bytes
so let's do byte B for buffer I don't
know so it's going to be byte buffer
don't allocate for dot is such a waste
of memory and stuff such a waste of CPU
time unless it's doing something
magically optimized and then we're going
to of course just hit up right with that
okay so you guys get the idea this is
what this is what this costs gonna be
and then finally the most important
thing I guess is the get buffer method
which is basically just going to return
this buffer of ours as an array so two
array I believe is correct
so there's one of these doesn't work
properly I swear so I'm just gonna
quickly yeah I mean it might we might
actually have to do this I really hope
not but let's just assume that this
works
okay I'm not sure okay so it's already
like you know not being happy about that
maybe you can do that see like why you
why you can't cost right can you in Java
finance so we might have to do what's
the point then we might have to do buy
it I really hope this works
result to array results or turn result
so does this are you kidding me
so it actually thinks the primitive is
not correct but they're the same thing
they're all day incredible incredible
no Java okay here we go so unbelievable
so you actually have to iterate through
it are you kidding me
sorry I'm just gonna share with you guys
what I'm reading here from my quick
google searching that's not under care
of that so you actually have to like are
you actually kidding me
this is ridiculous so I guess they are
different Wow Wow
this is uh this is great so what we'll
do then I guess is we'll just say that's
awful
okay so by it results I really hope this
one by the way what does this do
actually what list ArrayList so we need
to get to the ArrayList class and we
need to see what it does because I think
that one of these does the incorrect
thing or at least does this allocate a
new array or do we have to give it one
it's already allocated that's my so
array copy are full of lot what's the
array so a is the thing if a dot length
is less in size then making you array of
A's so maybe it will cause if the length
I guess oh well that's gonna null
pointer exception actually so it looks
like we do actually have to give it an
array that is the right size this would
all be solved if we could just store you
know bytes like this but of course we
can't become foot I don't know why for
whatever reason okay I'm not gonna get
frustrated with Java today this is a
happy episode
maybe I'm Java in wrong so if you guys
have a better way of doing this please
post like a link to like a paste bin
page or something because I I can't like
I actually can't believe that this is
what people are supposed to do guess
sighs let's just sighs
so to array we make another bytes so
this is just a lovely Feast of
allocations going on right here then we
copy everything which I guess I'll just
do using a for loop and I guess we can
just do that or do we actually need to
like yeah so we can do that because they
are equal but if they're arrays its
although it's all over which doesn't
make any sense because the memory should
be the same anyway that doesn't matter
this is our massive get buffer thing
which would have been one line at C++
but point is we've got this now so this
is what we're gonna do we're data we've
got data which is basically going to be
the way that we're gonna set itself is
we're gonna have our binary writer there
might be a class of Java again as I said
that already does that I just felt like
writing my own to show you guys what it
would actually do now I don't know what
the slides are gonna be and we don't
care too much anyway so we do write a
dot rice we pass in our packet header
and then we pass in our packet type
connect thing right so we do write a dot
write packet type connects okay and
that's gonna be it and then what we can
do is just again hit ops and writer get
buffer and that's all we need to do as
far as a connection packet goes okay so
hopefully the server will receive this
again we can check really easily if I
just go to the server real quick our
dump thing right now actually as you can
see creates a string out of the data
which is not what we want to do at this
point what we're actually going to do is
dump the binary the way we're going to
do that is basically go through each of
the weather data data dot length we're
gonna go through each byte individually
we're going to get up system dot out dot
print line or will actually do print F
and you guys will see where I'm going
with this in a minute is that yep
correct okay good
we're gonna start off with two tabs
actually no we're not gonna do this
let's just for that it's a little bit so
we'll start off with we'll do a print
what we start off with two tabs and then
we'll do a print F which will basically
take in dark
so let's see I'm going to take in a
percentage sign X which means formatted
as a hexadecimal thing I don't know if
we can tell it to actually be two digits
though so we can even do like zero one
instead of just one but we'll see what
happens
so we'll do that and then we'll do data
I of course okay and then every time
we'll do every I plus 1 mod 4 so every
four iterations skipping the first one
of course every four bytes
maybe every eight bytes or something
will make a new line so we'll say every
eight bytes so when that equals zero
we'll just do a system to add a print
line backslash N and then another two
times right and then at the end of this
we'll also do a print line okay that way
we'll have some reasonably formatted
output I will actually add like two
spaces in between all these bytes as
well but now now what we should be doing
is printing bytes right so we'll quickly
go back here and just format that nicely
let's start up the server so go server
debug as let's just quickly write some
code here that said something like okay
let's assume that started successfully
so I'll do something like started server
on port a 192 server is listening
okay again we can probably handle some
better logging later I just wanted to
set something up really quickly just to
get this to work so we'll start off a
java application okay good
at least we know that's happening we'll
start our game which should send that
finishing packet so we'll start that as
a java application
okay that was huge first of all but
we'll go back to will stop this let's
say debug or what's going on let's stop
that okay
and we'll stall this ever I guess as
well so here's what we have we have a
huge amount of data it seems okay so you
can see you can see that the packet it's
sent is absolutely massive okay we'll
talk about that later but also you can
say that in terms of what we've received
I think one space would be enough but
you can say that in terms of what we've
received like probably print 16 it is I
think in one line there's 40 40 and is 1
and the rest is just zero now the reason
it's so big I'll quickly mention that
now it doesn't really matter but
honestly the reason it's big big
remember is because when we create data
so that's just going from the packet
actually that's send we have a max
packet size which I think we use
somewhere yes so yeah so over here when
we receive the data buffer right then we
kind of decide to stock without receive
it you can see that we receive 1024
bytes so the rest of them are going to
be empty now we can actually check how
big it is if we actually do something
like packet dot yet I think there's a
proper way because unfortunately the
data is not gonna be there needs to be
there should be a way to see how many
bytes it actually read unfortunately I
don't remember what that he is there
so we receive a package
okay okay okay get length it seems as
the right thing so get length okay so we
can do that and if we do that or be fine
so let's remove that space as I said
let's maybe make sixteen of these in one
line and then that should be good so
we'll start that up real quickly again
so we'll do a debug as driver
application debug as java application
close the game go back to our server and
you can see that in this case here it is
I don't know where we got that I'm not
sure anyway you can see that we received
three bytes which is correct what
actually is that what are we printing
after that I'll we're print were
printing it as a string anyway okay so
let's not do that
I think well why do we leave that in
there we should I'm here no it doesn't
matter we'll get rid of that new string
thing because that's what the app signs
are for okay cool so we're receiving the
connection pack is successfully
basically so when we process it again
we'll see we have two kind of ways to
process stuff we have a we have a you
know checking to see if a string equals
I'll say DB and then we'll also have one
other thing which as I said we have this
thing so what we'll do is else if I
don't know how to do this man
so we we need to check to see if the
first two bytes are
look I might just do this because I
honestly don't know how to do this
properly in Java so we'll do that
and I promise you we will fix this so
then the third bite will be the type
so again if the case is one which I
might just format as that for now even
though it is exactly the same of course
we can say something like received
connection packet okay again really
quick test to run so if we just we
should get that hopefully if we just go
ring server and in fact I might go to
game and just not send that I'll see
database because I really don't care
about that so we'll quickly debug that
de beauté that some people might say
okay cool so there we go so we didn't
actually receive connection back
wonderful why not let's go back to
server and see what happened so why did
it not like my thing well that's clearly
false right we dumped the packet if da20
is that that is what we send and outer
one is that I doubt it - whoops whoops
because out of three would have been
zero because it's empty
it's filled with zeros so let's do that
again debug as Java replication debug as
java application and this time hopefully
we would have yet received connection
package beautiful so what are we gonna
do with that connection packet well I'm
glad you asked because we are quickly
since we're running out of time we're
gonna quickly I'll show you guys the
main idea I did hope to get more done
this episode but we had to write that
whole binary writer thing and everything
but in our server what we'll do is we'll
have a we'll have a client now I don't
really want to call this client because
because it's maybe I'll call it serve a
client
just because when I search for client
and stuff even though they are in
different namespaces or different
packages like I kind of you know I think
it's better just having it maybe serve a
client so this is what a serve a
client's gonna have they're gonna have
an address it's gonna have and this is
like roughly gonna be like a P OD kind
of structure like it's gonna be plain
old data just like this is just gonna be
like a struct really just filled with
information we need to describe our
client I'll probably end up adding
methods and functionality to it anyway
but we'll just have the basics thing
making basic things like address and
port and maybe like a status okay which
for now might just be a boolean so maybe
this is more or less and is kind of
connected thing okay and again since
this is gonna be kind of a PID structure
I'm gonna make everything public because
again it's just going to be a struct so
public server clients and I guess we can
create a new client within dress and a
port and then we'll set aside us true I
don't really know we'll just do that for
now
I'm whoops we need to make sure we
assign these hobbies okay
so what's gonna happen is when we
receive a connection packet inside our
server what we'll do is the server will
actually have a private list for now
we'll refer to it as a list well we
might change that data structure into
something a little better like like a
like a set maybe that would be a lot
better yeah we'll probably make it a set
eventually I just wanna deal with
hashing right now but we'll make it a
set or maybe even a notice that would be
fine yeah we'll make it a set I mean
what's the what's it gonna we could
optionally make it like a hash table or
hash map and then have the keys be the
user name because that would be quite a
fast hash instead of having the whole
object we might do that anyway
yeah well okay here's what we're gonna
do we're gonna we're gonna quickly set
us up as a set
actually so we'll have a set of seven
clients cold clients we're going to meet
there's a new I think hash set yeah and
I know you don't have to write it in
here but I like writing it twice anyway
just so I know what's happening
makes the code a little bit more
readable so clients what's going to
happen is when we actually create
receive a connection packet we're gonna
say clients don't add new server clients
packet dots get address packet get port
okay congrat like we've got our our
client now and the one thing I will do
is we will like to a to do will be to
have a username okay so what we'll do is
well actually we will store a or at
least two user ID I think like at least
for now so we'll have something like
public int user ID which for now again
this is gonna be a bit stupid but there
with me it's fine and it will work
private static and user ID counter maybe
some of you see where this is going so
we're basically going to assign user ID
to user ID account to plus lots which
means that it will every time it creates
a new server client it will increment
that static field meaning that we'll get
a unique user ID for each client all the
way up to about two billion which should
be enough
I think so we'll be fine maybe we'll
start it at one there just because 0
might be like you know no user ID or
invalid or something weird okay so there
we go we've got a user ID ID now and
since that is unique what we can do is
and I think that I'm actually not even
sure let's just quickly look up object
and see what the hash code is an int
okay so let's take this that what I want
that wasn't native okay
anyway I'm assuming that I can just say
public and hash card and then
override that right nope
how do I do this I'm assuming hashcode
is water what do we use for set/sets
anyway no that's a capital C so you're
happy with that okay and then I'm just
going to return because I think it
returns the memory address or something
like that or the object ID by default
but we want to the reason I'm changing
hash code is because we might want to
compare you know two objects together
for a that for example or just happy
like just because we we might create a
new server client object with the same
user ID or something with the same
address and all that stuff and we don't
want it to think that that's a different
object cuz it is still the same user of
course because we use user ID instead so
we can again just return a user ID as
our hash code that will be a unique
value so that's all we need to basically
used our hash for so that we can like
that will be our hash and then we can
look up
that'll be I'll look up into the set
right so those of you don't know first
of all because I don't think starts to
used that often oh I don't think sets
the users often say should unfortunately
a lot of people a lot of kind of amateur
programmers I'll say we'll just use a
list for everything I like an ArrayList
for everything and you know whilst that
is okay and probably wouldn't have a
huge performance penalty in our case
because there aren't billions of or even
thousands of clients having something
like a set makes sense so set is
basically a constant time lookup because
it uses a hash function to figure out
where the object you're looking for
actually is in memory and of course the
only only requirement for a set over
list is that every object there has to
be unique right obviously because
otherwise if you have two objects with
the same thing well you can have like a
multi set but we won't talk about that
because they're stupid you can have a
set you know you can't have duplicate
objects because then it wouldn't know
which one to get right so typically if
you know you're always going to have a
set of unique objects use a set because
your lookup times are going to be so
much faster if you're searching for an
object if you never have to search for
objects if all you're interested in is
just
raining over the list again and again
and again then maybe just use the list
right but of course if you need specific
objects like for example I want to find
churner as my client how do I do that
having a set it's gonna be way better
you can also like eventually will
probably like we can still use what
other thing I mean cuz again what we're
doing right now we're hashing based on
just the user ID so that's not ideal but
it's just at the beginning will
eventually probably hash based on the
name of the user that way you can
quickly create a new server client
object with just a name and then that
will be kind of your way to compare and
like retrieve ones that you want so
anyway now that we've done this if we
basically go into I will basically go up
here into listen and on the process
maybe up here I will set a breakpoint or
something well in fact I don't even need
to I'm just gonna run this server and
then the client close the client under
the server I'm going to hit pause switch
into the debug view and then what I
should see is under variables which I
see nothing I mean what I should see let
me just switch the right throat I guess
listen thread oh well maybe I'll just go
into the stack trace yeah here we go you
can see that inside this I should have
clients I just realize this as a set so
it's probably nothing we have sized one
in here I don't know if I can actually
there it is kay serve a client okay we
can say we've got an honor address which
will be equal to we can't really see it
but it'll lamina set object and port of
course five seven thirty sixty which is
our port status is true user IDs one
okay so there's our object we've
successfully connected a client the
server now retains that client meaning
the server can now send you know a
message to all clients or something like
that so we have that going on and of
course the next step would be replying
to the client and being like hey I've
received your connection
I've added you to the list lit this list
you are now connected to the server and
that's what we're going to cover next
time if you enjoy this video please hit
the like button if you really enjoy this
video and you want access to the source
code and you want to support the series
then feel free to pledge on patreon just
five dollars a month will get you access
to a private github repository which is
over here which contains every single
commit or rather every like a commit for
each episode of game programming so that
you can you can compare the code changes
between every episode and so that you
can just download the code without
having to copy it if you prefer to just
kind of sit back relax and watch the
videos without having to type along so
anyway and of course that helps the
series out and ensures that I can keep
putting out these videos alright that's
it I'll see you guys next week yeah
Cherno out fool
you